despite being a relatively nascent
eSport Rainbow six siege is in no
shortage of jaw-dropping place plays
that have already etched themselves into
the annals of eSports history Mavs all
alone outside but young all alone on his
roster as he's gonna end up picking up
three kills oh my god what is that does
that now we've taken pains to document
in many such moments from the rushes to
the clutches to the nitro cells but you
always buckle up because today we're
coming for the whole shebang Juan and
Gohan will go down
no more IQ turns the second Astro demo
boys are you ready for this oh thank you
are you kidding me with a third getting
take it down and then drop right below
three movies banco today we're counting
down the top 10 plays in the history of
competitive rainbow 6 siege alright
let's get this thing started with the
time that laxing used fat sure to bring
the Thunder against evil geniuses and
the quarterfinals of the 2018 US
Nationals from a fuel knife kill to a
goose bump inducing Popoff this is a man
who's channeling his inner warrior come
on
this is what siege is all about rushing
straight through the knife from waxing
dispatches of neck rocks rushing through
hey we'll take down gotcha
seven seconds last Easter Bunny
what thing the one manifested a cloud
nine it's a massive multi Frank to not
only Patty's that's but to outright
clutch the road for cloud nine and give
them the most definitive lead we have
seen from a team so far in this matchup
taking the nine spot on our list is aces
slapping a nice big example of his
namesake on two ninjas in pajamas in the
group stage of the Paris major watch as
the Australian anchor railroads his way
through three unsuspecting attackers
before dumb stirring the fourth in the
most jaw-dropping way imaginable
plant going down someone successfully
but no aces season aces coming in can he
get it to big kills from aces he sees
another on third aces oh my goodness in
a one thing done the mice troubleshoot
away at the wall this is a bad how does
this happen
oh my word ace is a huge clutch and
he'll get the diffuser fanatic my god
what happens when you put the fate of
around in Young's hands whatever you
need coming in at number eight is the
time evil geniuses storied support
pulled off a 1v4 against faze clan in
the semi-finals of the pro league season
nine playoffs in Milan listen up kids
this right here is why you always take
the shoddy SMG 11 combo on smoking Mavs
all alone outside but young all alone on
his roster is he's gonna end up picking
up brake hills oh my god what is that
God kill
does that what was that young in the 1v4
clutches the smoke trapped inside a
small office taking the seventh spot on
our list is Dan making one of the
crispiest clutches in the history of
siege the one that capped off team
empires downright impossible comeback in
the grand finals of pro league season
nine left scrambling in the 2d five
Danny's able to bum rush the Monty
before closing out the cleanest of 1v2
is against Iggy's last remaining
attackers this could go very bad for
Empire who are bailing themselves out of
a bad situation with Gio down below this
could be the end of each G's miracle
return to form Dan will come up now as
well but Gio could possibly catch the
maestro off-guard
the maestro looks the wrong way will be
able to on the fight no Gio does this
will prompt Dan to have to do double
duty and then became will watch as Gio
goes for the plant the sound cue will
give Tim the information only takes what
down fire will rise as you crown a new
champion here
on an edition of dan to this team proves
to be what's needed and this miracle
comeback from evil geniuses will be all
but a dream Empire are your season nine
champions coming in at number six is a
play whose brilliance can be captured in
just two words trigger discipline
watch's vitality spark bestows a
beat-down on an unsuspecting ends before
calmly closing out the post plant nez
spark gets pushed on he is very wisely
not getting the initial fret kids at Red
Bull kill Wilkie now I don't want merge
this one here it comes Wilkie checks the
wrong angle and he goes back in for the
defuser there's no time spark clutches
it out in a 1 versus 4 we just saw
firsthand why'd you wait when you're in
that position to strike and you hesitate
for that moment you have two real
options you either pay for it
immediately or you fully capitalize and
Wow vitality snags around that they
really at the start didn't have any
business in winning what would you look
at that we were able to make it halfway
through our list without a pen to play
unfortunately that streak ends here
since it's time to talk about Pangos
basement hold against team font in you
too season 2 of pro league if there's
one play that shows what a perfect match
Pingu and smoke really are it's this one
Newt knew two [ __ ] one and
Gohan will go down are you kidding
[Applause]
the first play to crack our top four is
joysticks epoch defining ace against g2
in the grand finals of the Raleigh major
there's just something symbolic about
watching Empire star player unravel the
g2 dynasty one frag at a time not only
was it an earth-shattering play it
marked an important moment in the
history of rainbow 6 eSports even though
we had a moment
number one it wasn't the fastest there
you go joist oh okay
joystick got that kill on his very final
bullet so fat a good luck and good aim
on his side of things there's another
four joystick for team Empire came onto
the heart breacher
about a four takes down Bobby and
alright Oh what the hell joystick the
man the madness all five kills and the
answers beautifully on to g2s first
round hasta la vista baby kicking off
our top three is a play that needs no
introduction
Pangos 1v2 to cap off Penta sports this
Invitational win in 2018 not only had
Penta just clawed their way back from a
two map deficit their championship
winning point came down to their star
player pulling it out of the fire in a
clutch post plant situation the rest as
they say is history as they start to the
future and you go for one on the second
the best team
invitation the most wins now of any team
including a whole world championship
evil geniuses just let it slip by an
inch
taking the penultimate spot on our list
is the time that nest pulled off a 1v5
against pain gaming in the
latin-american semi-finals of pro league
year - season 1 there's really no way to
introduce this one you kind of just have
to watch it I didn't mean a [ __ ] about
you or your desk you know poke you
brainy my budget isn't really poke you
want to cut lemansky official energy go
get stuck with this your grandfather he
would Stassi you said I can't believe I
really do pick so many other - go say
you clutch is a koala Luke let's keep
Portugal until Alpha buzzy taking the
top spot on our list is the shortest
filthiest and most awe-inspiring ace in
the history of Rainbow six siege that's
right it's the time that during the
group stage of the 2019 Invitational
hungry wiped out all of nor Arango in
six seconds flat down three nothing and
eager to make a dent into their deficit
hungry goes in on or Arango with nothing
but a Candela and a dream
fortunately his targets lined up just
right making this one of those plays
that you just have to see to believe
and there go the candelas from hungry
watching him out he's gonna wash
straight through the all that yeah his
ash had made two blind they're trying to
go for three hungry we got a ball
looking it for four hungry
I agree you are absolutely wild and
pensive bring one back oh my goodness
there is a reason ladies and gentlemen
that you banging away from this man and
you're gonna see it right there well
that's our list be sure to like the
video subscribe to our Channel and let
us know in the comments what other plays
you think we could have included also be
sure to check out the link to our new
don't at me podcast in the description
below see you next time I don't know I'm
trying more energy energy
that's not my my mass the impression of
chante ever more energy
[Music]